in the federal reserve's most recent
policy meeting china's coveted lockdowns
were mentioned eight times
the country's zero coveted policy
triggered near total quarantines earlier
this year across several major cities in
an effort to contain the spread of the
omicron variant still china has reported
its first domestic cases of the highly
contagious ba-5 subvariant and overall
coveted cases are rising at their
fastest pace in nearly two months
clearly the fed is aware whatever
happens next in china could be a big
deal for the us economy chinese social
media platforms are full of talk that
another wave of lockdowns could be on
the way
in shanghai where residents are still
recovering after months of being stuck
at home
a number of apartment blocks and
neighborhoods are once again subject to
restrictions
macau china's gambling hub has seen over
1500 confirmed covet infections since
mid-june
and temporarily closed casinos for the
first time in over two years
the island is also prohibiting residents
from leaving their homes except for
essential activities
casino operators including las vegas
sands mgm and win are expecting to make
no revenue in the near future
according to tim we an economist at
moody's analytics china's economic
picture is quote very muddled as data
shows the lag effect of the city-wide
lockdowns
most experts had rosy outlooks at the
beginning of the year but have since
revised them significantly lower
china's economy saw a major slowdown in
the second quarter of 2022 after its
lockdowns
the country's gdp grew by just 0.4
percent compared with a year ago
shanghai and ji lin which experienced
full lockdowns saw their fiscal revenue
slump by 52 and 79 respectively in april
to may compared with a year ago
according to bank of america analysts
the impact of the lockdowns affected
several major u.s companies including
apple and tesla which both faced supply
chain issues in china a second lockdown
in chinese manufacturing centers whether
full or partial would stall the recovery
of the global supply chain and give an
additional upward push to prices paid by
american industry and consumers
observers are split on how severe the
impact would be to the u.s
some believe it would prove to be just a
blip in america's economic recovery but
others including the fed say it could
reverse recent global supply chain
improvements
much depends on the chinese government's
adherence to its own zero-coveted policy
but most experts are in agreement that
china's hospitalization and death rates
are not rising in a way that would
justify more city-wide lockdowns brendan
ahern chief investment officer at
china-focused etf provider crane shares
believes the government will likely go
with a more moderate and targeted
approach to future lockdowns ahern says
quote the cost of the shanghai lockdown
showed that there's a very significant
economic consequence to having a blanket
response he adds that the chinese
government is very dialed into public
sentiment and shanghai's citizens have
no desire to repeat a full lockdown
you